Where are you going, Mizutoku, where are you going?
If you say you're going out, I'll go to the bookstore, and
Iida too
Hey, Mom, I have
n't set
it.
I
don't want to take care
of you.
Thank you for the meal
Oh,
stand up
Thank you for the meal
[Music]
I'm glad that both of you seem to
be
doing well What is it
?  Even in
an age when there is a big family structure, there
is no
such thing as brothers and
sisters.  Yo, I'll take
the relationship between you and me to Akabane
Alright,
11. There's no way to look down on you from above, since when did that happen?
How
long will I be famous for
you? Why do
I have to keep being called by
my first
name casually?
What else can I call you? It
's
more and more suitable to call
you Onee-chan Because
we're brothers, it
's Suzy to call you Onee-chan,
right?
I
'll explain to my brother-in-law who's brain cells are resting
Listen to a lot of baiting Like
this, if you were born earlier,
you'll be my sister or brother This is the premise number 1 And I was born earlier than you
this is before
If I remember correctly
, you and I have the same birthday on November 3rd.
That's not the limit, is
it?
I asked Uncle Aki to find out about it.
My birth was at 11:14am,
and your birth was at 11:34am.
Ushiki In Japan, the first of the twins to be born was called the
younger sister at the beginning, right
? We who entered weren't
twins.  But right now,
the one who was born first did
n't sell.
'Cause if I'm your little brother, I
'm sorry
No wait, even if we stare at each other like this, it wo
n't be clear.
You're right
,
then how about something like this?
From now on, we have
to hide our previous relationship and
live as
reasonably close brothers-in-law.  You might end up doing that,
so
what about losing? A song
about acting like a brother-in-law would make you a younger brother or a
feather and a younger
sister.
By the way, does this rule apply to bankruptcies and
places
where Uni-san isn't around?
I
'll do it ok let's do
it from now on
Then what are you doing on your own
?
Even if the act is
clearly harassment, it cannot be raised without a reason
.
That's why I proposed this rule
Water
is the only Pandora's box in my room It's something
that should never be found there
Come on
Ah,
I
don't want to say anything that would match you.
We don't call each
other,
no, you
're out too, so it's only natural that
you
don't want
to fight with each other, right?
[Music]
Sound,
kyun, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah,
well, if you learn this,
don't think that you
're trying to mess with
me.
Wow,
I didn't mean to be mean,
but I was in 4th place. I'm
sorry.  If it's just gone, it's okay
We're getting closer
[music]
Same class,
same last name
, pretending to be someone else Okay, cheese, it's
too difficult I
'll post separately from tomorrow, so
that's a matter of course
You should put your heart and soul into making friends
instead, don't you?
Who made your high
school debut?
I have a deadly weapon, so I'm going to start the
opening
ceremony from
now on
.
[Music]
Next, the words of the new student representative
Mr.
Iri
Domu-san.
just say you don't
do it  I want to be there, but even after waking up, I'm
still studying and I still can't get rid of my sense of liberation
Why is this girl getting better grades than me
?
You go to junior high school, but you
don't really play games, so it'd
be nice if you could do something about it, so this time it's me.
Did you gossip that you were your brother-in-law?
I'm sticking to my brother-in-law's side
Did you receive a lot of responses?
I don't know Yokoshima,
so I want to step on her to get closer to that woman
What
is it?
I'm trying to do it I don't like it I mean it's
just a matter of letting it go and not dating
That was a promise What the hell
are you thinking?
You're my brother, aren't you?
Haa~ It
was a nice buy
Oh
, what to make I decide what to make with what's in the fridge
Well, what do I have?
What happened
to the chicken breast
?
And that
feeling when I pressed it, I
forgot about the way
I
erased
it from my wings until now.
That man's cold-hearted mother,
Sukata,
isn't it?
Is it possible that
Mizudo was just a
bad boy who looked at his brother-in-law with lewd eyes
?
Until Heisei book
Shina
nan Jae
pu
[music] N
Shudai
Wait
a minute It doesn't seem like I'm living a good life I was the center
eh
hey
ah I guess you thought you were going to make fun of me anyway
but I
regret it  Did
n't you realize that even though you're usually quiet, you sometimes do crazy things with impetus?
It's my family, so
he shouldn't be licked by his family
Thank
you, Scott
, say something.
Music:
Today, it's
my reason
.
But I'm desperate If my mother didn't come home
[music]
ni
[music] I got
it wrong, so take it off once and
it won't be solved by cheese egg snow
than
me
n there was
[music]
i am
even if I say na na
w
today
[music]